condley Jamaica 3 so an extra possession
good activity Donnelly was a wide-open
JMO
so no matchup that impels went one way
they couldn't scramble back the other
way changes but one change we really
like is 14 on the offensive rebound is
that been successful so far
and are there other subtle changes on
the rise add some pace to it and I think
the game looks great and it's a it's a
small change but I that boat close we've
enjoyed and so far it's working
wait with you Noah
drives on Kuzma spins and finishes with
one point line it's good out of a time
out to come out a lot of play that works
get an easy shot good score it's a mate
three out of six as no
gets the EE D here's a slip to an 89 see
if they can do a better job scoring but
right now partner do a better job than
spending the three-point line Polly drop
down this way
nice Drive good district cut brain be a
starting 5 snack basket stick let's
hopefully now field shoot point increase
all night ok no one was inside Kevin
Love has been out since late October
gotta clean it up
Payton turns it over bad things happen
when you leave your feed to make a pass
it's an easy one but now it's 11 points
off turnovers Carter wants Noah and
he'll get it and he'll get a tactical
this can't be for this can't be for a
hangover
and you turn around and say something
[Applause]
didn't do a chin-up buddy huh sadly 22
and 11 and the Tuesday night loss to
Toronto in his first career start Joakim
Noah more times a nut doesn't work out
you see a quick pass nice drop off there
by Connelly but Kazmir trying to throw
that bounce pass never allow my
colleagues on sabonis this is not a
Indiana team that goes to the free-throw
line and off a lot and Noah what you
want to work against Sabonis bridges
have to be smarter with their hands glue
their feet and pretty good recovery by
Doug McDermott is Noah baseline the big
that setting the screen just loves our
son we don't give up a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
doing what
guard up the and defensively they've
been trying to do some things with awful
incident that just found so ha
and McDermott were briefly teammates in
New York fourth quarters flooring deals
his knife assists of the game
[Applause]
drag of the screen by Kali so for smiles
have to stay longer than he would like
that allows and roll hard and good
things will happen you've got to do it
Joakim Noah just like that swings it
down over Dario's charge again Joakim
Noah throws that right with facing shot
clocks data poor Joakim Noah turned it
back the clocks
he thinks it's 2013 again you know what
he can do which is school that done it
against the Grizzlies only everything
five again
[Applause]
this game today there the dribble hop
control again is Joakim Noah no able to
get nice catch and finish at the front
of the room on a perimeter
[Applause]
in its younger career but here how about
this will be a difficulty
[Applause]
season
there's border fighters Quincy's team is
no one gets out or tunity he is not
letting it go by the wayside 25 minutes
pick-and-roll
this is earlier and hey that is strength
because Randall was right there in the
room with me Spurs seventh in the West
Noah
right ghosts above the screen help there
no help
as it alter its being a focal point in
DeRozan
again not a fad frequency before half
for there's a No
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm down two in a row joki layout good
dear Felicio now you can't let Joakim
Noah beat you off the dribble from the
three-point line he's not gonna take it
three doesn't work out well because they
are into a comfort level where they work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Tyler Dorsey in for the first time
tonight jump shot in here
beautiful dumped off for three shots I
think you need to stop Trump is little
getting inside more and then worry about
the three-point shot later the bullet
got to the rack he was recently food
heavily in New York when the Grizzlies
went through Ingram was 11
Noah straight line drive the Grizzlies
on an 11 to 4 run no Noah stream
Chandler drives floats it up
[Applause]
no of things I'll build what it does
best staying still shooting the
difference Lakers five of eight verses
for 14 from distance Lakers would come
back
no that's the Lakers right there
defensively two guys rotate away from no
Lakers have gone seven minutes without
field going parsy's so I got to get the
back away
[Applause]
[Music]
turnover of the game and Ilan right
feeling very comfortable to the Econo on
the defense Selden
no whistle no nothin
don't
tibe at was hard to say who's winning at
that battle if he's wrapping around a
waist that's the easy with the traveling
dump up Noah slams Rosie's lead the
average is fewer than six Noah drives on
marketing capacity
CJ
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nowhere on another offensive
rebound what's up you guys it's Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for more video
content